une bande de copines c'est avant tout ça
l'esprit du rugby féminin
nous sommes sur la pelouse du club de
gien briard dans ce territoire plutôt
rural le club a compris qu'il fallait
jouer collectif il s'est associé à
montargis afin de séduire de futurs
espoirs du rugby féminin
des actions sont mises en place dans les
établissements scolaires pour faire
découvrir la discipline
et ça marche j'étais au collège il y
avait une section rugby est en fait
c'était soit ça soit la littérature donc
j'ai essayé le rugby est finalement
restée longtemps on dit que les filles
sont plutôt littéraire au basket chez
pai a quand on avec d'autres équipes
qu'on les affronte
il ya moins de respect il ya un
fonctionnement de valeur et du coup j'ai
moi je préfère le réduit sens où le club
croit dans le rugby féminin et espère
qu'une équipe seniors voient le jour en
2000 21 équipes issues de joueuses
locales pour le président les filles ont
une force mentale particulière
alors ce que des garçons se prépare une
compétition juste avant un match sont
dans les vestiaires c'est souvent quand
on se met un peu des instruments et des
coups on s'encourage par le cri nos
cadettes elles sans courage par le
silence c'est à dire qu'à une force qui
est à l'intérieur d'elle-même et elles
n'ont pas besoin de crier ou de se
mettre des baffes pour se donner du
mental voilà la différence
aujourd'hui le rugby féminin est en
plein essor dans la région
à gien les filles représentent un tiers
des licenciés soit 66 joueuses dimanche
les moins de 18 ans accueillent sur leur
terrain un tournoi regroupant les
meilleures équipes du grand ouest
un bon test ces jeunes filles brillantes
seront peut-être demain psychologue prof
d'anglais ou encore keane et elles
seront surtout l'élite du rugby français
avec une équipe qui devrait voir le jour
d'ici six ans en attendant elle
recherche une jeune coiffeuse pour
démêler jeu